un père son fils tout de passionnés de
BMX et un même objectif se faire plaisir
tous les samedis à l'entraînement sur la
piste de Voisins-le-Bretonneux en fait
je suis passionné de VTT depuis 20 ans
maintenant et je me suis toujours dit
que j'aimerais bien faire du BMX donc
j'ai attendu que mon fils est là qu'il
soit apte physiquement selon moi et donc
nous sommes inscrits il y a maintenant
trois ans qui est le meilleur pilote
alors pour l'instant j'ai encore un peu
d'avance mais je pense que d'ici deux
trois ans normalement si l'évolution va
s'y continue à faire du BMX ça devrait
s'inverser assez rapidement comme il le
disait c'est pour l'instant c'est lui
qui est le plus
casse-couilles
parce que sinon si je reste comme ça ça
va rien faire plus casse-cou
non je pense que on n'est pas casse-cou
ni l'un ni l'autre qui le plus assidu
pendant les entraînements
oh c'est pareil oui oui
tant qu'il y a un entraîneur qui qui
dicte un peu les conduites à les
exercices à faire on est on est là on
est présent on n'est pas on se cache pas
je sais pas l'aventure familiale ne
s'arrête pas là puisque le petit frère
de Théo Sacha 6 ans et demi a rejoint la
tribu BMX cette année on se trouve en
famille et c'est toujours bien de faire
apprendre à son petit frère et de
transmettre quoi